was muss jetzt getan werden mehr als 500
infizierte in deutschland wie
expertinnen vorausgesagt hatten
explodiert die zahl der infizierten im
iran dort hat sich die solche
offensichtlich totgeschwiegen von den
machthabern unter dem radar so richtig
dramatisch ausgebreitet die zahl der
todesopfer ist dort von 17 auf 124
gestiegen
innerhalb von 24 stunden die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who hat
diese länder jetzt angeprangert wegen
ihres fehlenden engagement also was muss
jetzt getan werden die weko hat einen
bericht mit konkreten vorgaben
veröffentlicht mehr infos gibts übrigens
auf dem kanal ein fach medizin der ist
hier unter mir unbedingt abonnieren also
los geht's bei krieg zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen das ist ein
historischer tag heute ist die zahl von
weltweit 100.000 infizierten erreicht
worden
55.000 sind wieder gesund 3300 gestorben
und während die zahl der täglich neu
infizierten in china immer weiter sinkt
sieht die welt jetzt eine ähnliche
steigerung der ansteckung wie china
anfang des jahres doch in zahlreichen
ländern wie im iran wird zu wenig getan
und wie in italien wird das virus zu
spät entdeckt weltweit ist diese
entwicklung viel schwieriger zu stoppen
hat in china in einer diktatur was wir
nicht vergessen sollten
ende letzter woche hat die vero einen
großen bericht veröffentlicht darin geht
sie neben den eigenschaften des virus
und neben der situation in china auch
auf die schritte ein die jetzt global
unternommen werden müssen um mit cupid
19 umzugehen denn laut farrow ist das
saas kopf 2 durch die kombination aus
hoher übertragbarkeit und erheblicher
letalität also sterblichkeit in
entsprechenden risikogruppen einzigartig
unter den humanen coronaviren und ist
damit in der lage enorme gesundheitliche
wirtschaftliche und gesellschaftliche
probleme zu verursachen auch da
angenommen werden muss so die vero dass
alle personen auf der welt anfällig für
dieses virus sind spricht sich laut wie
alle anstecken können für länder die
bereits fälle von kogit 19 haben
empfiehlt die whu diese krankheit
äußerst ernst zu nehmen und sofort mit
der höchsten stufe des nationalen
krisenmanagements zu reagieren
sämtliche maßnahmen zur bekämpfung der
ausbreitung des virus zu mobilisieren
die länder sollen aktive suchen und
testen nach fällen und die isolation
dieser priorisieren sowie die
bevölkerung voll über die bedeutung und
den ernst von coop 19 aufklären daneben
empfiehlt die whu unverzüglich sämtliche
patienten und patientinnen mit
atypischen lungenentzündung auf das saas
koch 2 zu testen und auch manche
patientinnen mit erkrankungen der oberen
luftwege auf kurve zwei zu screenen um
infektionsketten aufzuspüren darüber
hinaus sollen die länder pläne für
strikte maßnahmen wie die sperrung
größerer versammlung oder schließungen
von schulen oder anderen institutionen
erstellen um in der zukunft mögliche
infektionsketten durchbrechen zu können
italien hat jetzt zum beispiel alle
kindergärten schulen und universitäten
geschlossen das macht extremen sind da
gerade bei kindern und jugendlichen die
strengen verhaltensregeln nicht
garantiert werden können abstand halten
und keine berührung gerade diese
konsequenten nichtmedizinischen konzepte
wie quarantäne absperrung bestimmter
gebiete usw sind laut das einzige
wirklich effektive mittel um
infektionskette zu unterbrechen oder zu
minimieren
jedoch schreibt die wiwo auch dass ein
großteil der weltgemeinschaft sowohl vom
mindset als auch materiell noch nicht
für die maßnahmen bereit ist die aber in
zukunft dringend benötigt werden könnten
um die ausbreitung zu verlangsamen und
um auch die gesundheitssysteme in
schwächeren ländern abzuschirmen
die einen ausbruch vom moffitt 19
ungleich schlechter bewältigen könnten
außerdem könnte so zeit gewonnen werden
zeit die unter anderem für die forschung
benötigt wird um das saas kopf 2 und den
ausbau besser zu verstehen um erkrankte
besser behandeln zu können und um
hoffentlich letztendlich eine impfung zu
finden aus diesem grund empfiehlt die
whu der allgemeinen bevölkerung neben
den basics wie händewaschen abstand
halten und so weiter bereit zu sein
maßnahmen gegen coop 19 auf verschiedene
weise aktiv zu unterstützen
einschließlich der einführung strengerer
distanzierung praktiken im sozialen
umfeld und der unterstützung der älteren
bevölkerung die besonders gefährdet
ist in frankreich wird zum beispiel von
besuchen in altenheim abgeraten zudem
empfiehlt die wiro sich immer wieder auf
den neuesten stand bezüglich kubik 19
und dessen anzeichen und symptome zu
bringen wie zb auf dem kanal von einfach
medizin am ende gibt es auch noch mal
ein link da täglich neue informationen
hinzu kommen und sich die lage und die
damals nötigen maßnahmen schnell ändern
könnten aber wie erkennt man bei sich
selbst das corona virus was für symptome
hat man bei coop 19
dafür hier anklicken anschauen und
einfach medizin abonnieren mega kanal
mit extrem fundierten informationen aber
ist gerade in diesen zeiten pflicht
würde ich mal sagen also bis dann bleibt
dran